I woke up craving Texas barbecue so bad,
so obviously lucky took me.
We've lived in Texas for a couple years now
and for some reason this is only the second time that we're having it.
Ended up going to Terry Blacks.
I thought it wouldn't be busy since we got there right when it opened,
but I was wrong. It was so busy.
Started off getting all of our sides
and then moved on to grabbing our meat.
Lucky ended up getting two pounds of the brisket
and I wanted some sausage so we ended up getting that as well.
I was so confused by this box of bread.
Someone please explain.
We weren't too hungry since we're not big breakfast people,
so we ended up getting we got some Mexican rice,
green beans, beans,
and then some pickles and onions.
I've come around to green beans and these were so good.
Before I could even start eating,
lucky was already on his second plate
and then also grabbed me some meat.
Brisket was so tender and I loved having the pickles and onions
as a palate cleanser in between.
I feel like Mexican rice is so underrated.
It's one of my favorite things to get.
Have no clue what that soda was,
but halfway through the meal I discovered that they had sauces
so I tried them. I didn't think it needed any,
but lucky disagreed with me.
This point I tapped out.
So lucky finished off almost All of our meat and our sides.
We cleared the table. And this was exactly what I wanted. It was so good.